let me just throw one quick video on
zelenski because guys don't worry we're
giving him an awful lot but at least
he's very thankful for it and you gave
us a huge support I want to thank to all
Americans who understand that it's more
than 43 billions for today it's big
support and I understand that it's all
your money but but
you have to know that you spend this
money for for not not just fighting you
spend this money for our lives
and I think that we save that the last
for for Europe and for all the world
Spencer bring us home quickly on this
one it's he thanks us it's all our money
and he's very thankful uh you're going
to be on this Earth past the time that
your dad and I are gone uh it's going to
be extra your money by the way yeah yeah
apparently Heaven professional I think
once both of you Shuffle off this Mortal
Coral is God will be about ready to
bring the curtain down so I don't have
to worry too much the whole thing the
Stars will fall from Heaven I know look
the U.S is not a charitable trust I will
go that far in the direction of real
politique I think it's absolutely true
that unless you make moral judgments
about regimes and leaders you can't
think seriously about the whole picture
in war so as you guys were both saying
it's not just it's so easy as to say
well you do what you have to do and
everything is relative to the situation
that you're in there are good guys or at
least there are less bad guys uh when
you're thinking about you know who your
allies are and what kinds of uh
civilizations you want to defend part of
our problem is that we have no idea what
our civilization is as dad was
indicating uh we basically our major
cultural export is like hormone blockers
for small children which is you know
extremely Bleak but accurate depending I
mean Al-Qaeda is painting over murals of
George Floyd in Afghanistan as we speak
you know now that we're now that we're
out but we don't exist it's like it's
very nice that zelens he is so so kind
to us to thank us for literally all of
our money
um but in reality in real world Politics
as we should be playing this the money
that we give to other countries is to
support our interests abroad and in so
far as supporting Ukraine does further
those interests I think there's a case
to be made that there's some money to be
spent there um but I'm actually not
interested in improving the quality of
life of other people simply for for the
mere sake of it there is something about
this uh discourse in America and
overseas that sort of treats us like the
World Bank that you just sort of dip in
whenever you need something and that is
a step too far